qu'est ce que tu as fait de beaux
pendant tout ce temps j'ai réappris à
vivre
et toi moi pour moi ça va très bien
merci
tu sais quand on bosse beaucoup on voit
pas le temps passer et vous aussi tu
arrêtais ton cirque cinq minutes mon
cirque c'est toi qui parle de cirque
pour qui l'être supérieur au dessus de
la mêlée tu croyais que sans toi
j'allais m'arrêter de vivre imaginer
quoi un coup d espoir et hop on se jette
par la fenêtre du rez-de-chaussée
tu sais de quelle hauteur exacte je suis
tombé non et j'en ai rêvé de mettre 50
espèce de trou du cul fais attention
jugée tu n'as pas encore signé son
contrat
tu sais ces pages dactylographiées en
plusieurs exemplaires au bas des
quelques semaines croit
voilà elle est un peu fatiguée mais bon
pour aujourd'hui
allez on y va pour un grand cri d'amour
on parle de cirque il faut pour qui
l'être supérieur au dessus de la mêlée
qui croyaient que sans toi j'allais
m'arrêter de vivre
sinequa a coûté espoir et on jette par
la fenêtre du rez-de-chaussée
tu sais de qui l'auteur exact je suis
tombé non et jean mérelle peut mettre 50
espèce de trou duquel il fait attention
jugé tu n'as pas encore signé son
contrat
tu sais ces pages dactylographiées en
plusieurs exemplaires bon bah lesquels
tu mènes croire voilà